ليس تحيزا للنساء لكن لانهن الاكثر تعاطفا
مع الاخرين مقارنه بالرجال فالنساء يمتلكن
القدره على قراءه العقل فنظره واحده كفيله
بمعرفه ما يدور بداخل الشخص المقابل اضافه
للسعاده فكريا
قد يلمسو كثيرون هذا الشيء وقد يستغربه
البعض الا ان دراسه قام بها علماء من
جامعه كامبردج اكدت عمقه تعاطف الانثوي
المعتمد على نظريه العقل او ما يعرف
بالتعاطف في المعرفي
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن الدراسه فالواقع الملموس يعكس
ذلك ايضا فالمراه هي الام والزوجه والاخت
والصديقه ولكل من تلك المسميات فيضا من
المشاعر والعواطف والثعلب الاخر
ورغم كل هذه المعطيات الا ان الدراسه لم
تفسر سبب طاعته في النساء المعرفي الذي
يفوق ما يمتلكه الرجال الذين قد يعترضون
ربما على تفوق النسائي عليهم عاطفيا بل
وربما عقليا